um but the one thing like I think they
they preach from a young age is they
tell girls like they'll have a happy
ever after no matter what no they do
because they have these Catholic school
or not Catholic school they have these
Chastity speakers and I've seen
Christians I've seen Catholics and what
they'll do is like they'll be like oh I
was so broken and this girl like talks
about how she like basically she got ran
through and then still found a husband
and like okay that's good for you that
you found it but I can list 10 girls
that didn't happen for and if you make
those choices there might not be someone
to bail you out at the end of the day
and that's like more of an honest
conversation then I was so broken which
one isn't even true you're horny shut up
like stop and like it's not broken when
you just make a poor decision